ويحيي الفلسطينيون اليوم الذكرى 47 ليوم
الارض الذي استشهد فيه سته فلسطين عام سته
وسبعين من القرن الماضي داخل الخط الاخضر
وذلك خلال تصديهم لقرار الابتلاء على
اراضيهم في مناطق الجليل والمثلث والنقب
ان ينظم الفلسطينيون اليوم مسيرات شعبيه
للتاكيد على تمسكهم بارضهم لاسيما في
سخنين وعرابه في الجلي بينما دعت حركه فتح
لتنظيم فعاليات لاحياء هذه الذكرى في
انحاء مختلفه من الضفه الغربيه المحتله
كما صدرت دعوات مماثله لتنظيمها عند حدود
قطاع غزه وبدورها دعت حركه حماس في ذكرى
يوم الارض الى تعزيز كافه اشكال المقاومه
خلال شهر رمضان دعت الى ذلك دفاعا عن
الارض وانتصارا للقدس والاقصى والاسرى كما
اكلت حماس في بيان لها ان الشعب الفلسطيني
لا يفرط او يتنازل عن اي شبر من اراضي
فلسطين من ارض فلسطين التاريخيه
من النهر الى البحر